hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wine mom tonight I want to talk about a
topic that I'm often asked not
necessarily in the comments or via text
but just in general life how do I know
that I'm pregnant and this is not about
me being pregnant this is about other
people wanting to know how they know
that they are pregnant not me I am NOT
having any more babies but I didn't
realize how much was in the bottle so
first I just want to say if you are
pregnant and genuinely wondering if you
are pregnant don't watch this video
because you will never know for sure
until you are in the doctor's office you
have gotten a blood test and that blood
test has confirmed that you are in fact
pregnant and also I'm not a doctor or
actually qualified to advise anybody on
anything I just like to drink wine on my
couch and I'm doing pregnant twice well
I got so first how soon can you find out
one thing that I did not realize when I
found out I was pregnant with my first
is that they calculate pregnancy from
the first day of your last period so if
you calculate from the first day of your
last period let's assume two weeks later
you ovulate you can know as soon as a
month after that whether or not you are
pregnant no for those of you who like
have this thought that you can like have
sex and wake up the next morning
realizing that you're pregnant there's
just no way you don't wake up the day
after having sex being like I think I
got pregnant last night it's like a
chalice of wine I will take a small sip
so let's talk about a couple things that
can happen when you take a pregnancy
test you can get false results they can
either give you a false positive or
false negative more typically it's a
false negative false positives are
pretty rare but they happen for example
I had a false positive on a pregnancy
test freaked out then I got my period
but then my period lasted like two weeks
and I was pretty confused because I was
like mentally preparing myself for like
a child and then I get my period and it
turned out to be a chemical pregnancy
which means the egg was fertilized but
it never embedded in the uterine wall
essentially it was releasing the
hormones that said I was pregnant but I
wasn't and then it just occurred like a
normal period
nothing but joy in this episode and also
you can take one and get a negative when
you are totally [ __ ] pregnant man like
you can be just at the very very early
stages of pregnancy and not urine test
does not pick it up enough so home
pregnancy tests are great they're a
great resource it's a great way to calm
your nerves or like figure out what's
happening but ultimately until you're at
that doctor's office getting a positive
yes or no from your doctor you don't
know for sure he's the real fun today
let's drink more so next let's talk
about early pregnancy symptoms there's a
fly in this room and I'm gonna kill it
where'd it go so first of all you might
have some food aversions for no reason
like for example when I was pregnant
with both of my sons at the very
beginning of my pregnancy I just wanted
to drink ranch dressing and that's all I
wanted to have and if this food isn't
drenched in ranch dressing I don't want
to eat it also you might blow a little
bit more than usual
but for me as the person who just like
floats up and down all day long like
that was never an issue next your boobs
might get super sore I remember when I
was pregnant with both of my kids if you
just like took two fingers and tapped
like right on the nipple area it would
not feel good also you might have some
light spotting or bleeding if you are
pregnant and I think a lot of people see
that spotting and either feel relieved
because they're hoping that they weren't
pregnant or feel disappointed because
they were hoping that they were pregnant
and they think that they're starting
their period you can get implantation
spotting which means that the fertilized
egg is implanting into the uterus and it
causes a little bit of bleeding and it's
something that looks like the start of a
period but it actually means that you're
pregnant and then last you're gonna get
some mood swings I remember being like
zero to 60 in two seconds just like
happy to sad for absolutely no reason
I'd see a commercial with puppies in it
and just be like but if all these
symptoms sound familiar and like
something that you've heard before it's
because they're all the same symptoms as
PMS really come on like
really why did the body have to do us
like that like here you go you could
either be getting your period or
pregnant with a child you don't know cuz
it's the same the last you will always
want to know how I found out that I was
pregnant because I've done it a couple
of times so with both of them I
experienced those very very similar PMS
symptoms of like bloating cramping sore
breasts like nausea I ended up taking a
pregnancy test as soon as I missed my
period both times it was positive and
then I went to the doctor and confirmed
but before I took that pregnancy test
and before I missed my period I had this
feeling that I was gonna miss my period
I don't know if it's intuition of your
body but I just knew and I think it says
something because both of my son's I
wasn't necessarily trying to get
pregnant so I wasn't like actively
looking for those signs or like hoping
for those signs
I just knew and this intuition doesn't
come like the day after you have sex
this isn't like a wake up the next day
and like oh my god I'm pregnant
but honestly pregnancy is so different
from mom to Mom I have so many mom
friends and all of our pregnancies and
the way we found out and the way that it
was were polar opposites and I mean in
every direction it is so different so
there's no one way of knowing whether or
not you're pregnant well there's one way
and that's going to the doctor not blood
test so that's all I got for today I'm
Hannah your friendly neighborhood wine
mom and if you have been pregnant and
found out about a pregnancy leave how
you found out in the comments or like
what your symptoms were how you found
out because I'm really curious to read
that and if you have a question or
anything you want me to talk about in
future episodes leave it in the comments
or text me I read all of them and just
remember that I like to give advice but
at the end of the day I'm not a doctor
I'm just a normal mom who drinks wine on
the couch so if you have any real
questions make sure to ask your doctor
he's safe don't take advice from me
[Music]
till next time I don't think I can
finish all this I'm Anika solidus
[Music]